hey guys it's justine and today i'm
going to take you through my streaming
gaming setup
[Music]
but first a huge thank you to lastpass
for sponsoring a portion of this video
they've been such a huge part of my
digital life for the past several years
and a huge supporter of my channel so
thank you guys so much lastpass is an
app that you can get on your phone on
your computer on ios on android it'll
remember all of your passwords all of
your usernames and it's also really
incredible because it will autofill them
but if you need to come up with a new
password it'll auto generate you a
complex password and it'll remember it
for you you'll have unlimited password
storage free cross device sync and
password sharing i'll put a link in the
description if you want to check out
lastpass and thank you again for
sponsoring a portion of this video some
of you might not know that i've actually
been streaming on twitch for the past
couple of weeks and it's been so much
fun so i thought that i would show you
what i'm streaming with and get some of
your suggestions on things that i need
for the future but this here is version
one of my stream setup i tried to keep
it as simple as possible but every time
i think i'm just going to do something
simple i'm just going to do a little
stream it of course gets out of hand
what started out as just a simple twitch
stream to talk to you guys and play
animal crossing has turned into a whole
nother thing it's tammy is it tammy
it's freaking tammy oh
that if there's a villager that i could
dig and put into a hole
it would be tammy
i've now been doing morning streams i
started discord server we brought the
entire justin tv crew back from 13 years
ago all of my original moderators
everybody's back hanging out and we're
having so much fun but i want to show
you guys what i've been streaming with
and my entire setup here because i've
been getting a lot of questions in the
chat so the centerpiece of this entire
setup is this monitor this is a 27-inch
razer raptor monitor and what's kind of
interesting is i have three different
things connected to this at the same
time i have my pc which is using the dvi
input my 18 core imac pro which i'm
actually using to stream off of i know
shocking and hdmi port is connected to
either my xbox or my nintendo switch
what's interesting about this is i
really don't like using dual monitors
for things i like everything to be very
central especially when i'm trying to
chat and game at the same time so what's
great about this monitor is i can use
picture in picture but this actually has
another option so if i wanted to have my
pc on this side and then my mac over
here i could be using my pc and the mac
at the same time
i know this is kind of what my screen
usually looks like when i'm streaming
i'll have animal crossing over here i
have my chat very close nearby and then
also my activity feed so i can see when
anybody subscribes or sends some bits
and then over here is streamlabs obs
that's what i am using to stream on from
my mac and the nintendo switch and then
under that is my discord server so if
you guys want to join the discord i will
also put a link in the description so
make sure you guys go check that out the
camera that i'm using is actually just a
webcam this is the logitech brio it's a
4k camera so the quality is actually
pretty good i do plan on upgrading this
to one of my sony cameras but i just
haven't yet because it looks good and
it's serving its purpose so i can't
really complain i also have really
incredible lighting so that really does
help make this camera look so much
better i'm using three different elgato
key lights these are amazing because
they connect to an app so i can turn
these lights on and off at the press of
a button i can control the color
temperature i also have it connected to
my stream deck i have this set up for a
few different actions with the press of
the button i can change from my
live setting which is what you're
looking at here
to just
chatting and then i can go to a be right
back screen if i have to go
to the body i keep talking in this
microphone like this is the microphone
that i'm using
and it's not i can mute the microphone i
have set up all of these different
actions i can mute discord if i'm
chatting with my sister or any other
friends when we're playing other games
the microphone that i'm using is the
hype mic by apogee you guys have seen me
talk about this before and what's really
great is you can also use this and plug
it directly into your iphone to your
ipad it also has a built-in compressor
so it has three different settings i
definitely recommend that if you do get
this microphone you test them out before
you just kind of go live i kind of just
keep it at one and call it a day it's
also great because this has a headphone
out i don't have to have an extra long
cord i just put these on and these are
the oh my gosh there is a balloon please
hold i
have to
shoot that down okay i got that and
these are the razer headphones i love
these these are really great they also
have a microphone so you can connect
these to xbox so i use this when i'm
doing gameplay or chatting with my
friends when i'm playing xbox you can
just plug it right into the controller
so these are multi-use headphones not
only for
streaming monitoring audio but also for
xbox chat
and editing these are i love you so much
even though i'm only playing animal
crossing right now the controller that i
use is the newest version of the xbox
pro controller which is amazing
just
feels great and then of course i use a
pro controller for playing animal
crossing so two different keyboards here
this is connected to my pc this is
razer's it's their special edition
stormtrooper one and it also has a mouse
to match the second keyboard i have is
connected to my imac this is just the
magic keyboard and then over here i have
a nomad wireless charging pad so i throw
my air pods on there i usually use air
pods when i'm doing zoom calls because
the headphones look a little aggressive
when i'm just doing like a conference
call or something so i'll connect these
do my zoom calls and let me tell you how
incredible i'm just gonna i'm just gonna
toot my own zoom horn here that sounds
weird but my zoom calls look incredible
i've got a green screen in the back i
can put myself anywhere my lighting is
so on point and the green screen we have
is also an elgato green screen this
thing is amazing because
i can either choose to have a green
screen or
choose not too
yeah so freaking cool i like this
because it gives me kind of just a
natural blank background and i have just
one of these nan lights tube lights
behind me and these things are really
great because they are rgb so i can
change the color to anything that i want
but i've just kind of been leaving it
this simple daylight color and
i think it looks pretty good let's put
that green screen back up
so i have my pc over here in the corner
and then under here i have my xbox and
my nintendo switch and both the xbox and
nintendo switch are hdmi so i just kind
of switch out the hdmi cables between
the nintendo switch and the xbox i feel
like i should probably get a switcher
i'm going to add that to my version 2
list but for right now it works pretty
well got a nice tray of amiibo here too
i use these when i'm playing animal
crossing
i told you guys that i play animal
crossing i'm not sure if you know or not
but
i play animal crossing they're my
friends
right
yes i have a problem this desk might
look good on camera but it is an
absolute nightmare it's a mirrored desk
it gets so smudgy especially when you're
a gamer and you're snacking and you're
just smudging stuff up being a smudgy
person that you are maybe you're not i
am i have to clean it like three times a
day
after every stream every time i sit down
it's such a nightmare but this again
is something that is a work in progress
i love these desks but i think i think
it might almost be time for them to to
be retired i also bought these at betsy
because
i would want to place things down but i
didn't want the microphone to hear and i
use them when i have my yerba mate for
my drinks
so just act like i have one right there
or a cup of water whatever it is that
i'm drinking that's nice because it'll
dampen the sound and you won't hear it
through the microphone i do need to get
a microphone arm that's also on my to-do
list there's a big list well it's not
that big it's like five things
i want a new gaming chair this chair is
really amazing it's from restoration
hardware it's not really a practical
aiming chair i do like it though because
i can't spin around like i'm stuck i
have to stay in one position and just
imagine nice pink gaming chair
anyway i've been enjoying streaming it's
been so much fun i'm sure some of you
guys might remember back in the day
about like 13 years ago when i was on
justin tv and then that later became
twitch it's really crazy coming back to
this community because a lot of the same
people are still there and since then
i've built a very
very amazing audience of really kind
incredible people and honestly you guys
are so amazing like just chatting in the
discord server and just hanging out on
twitter and in the chat it's been really
really fun so hopefully you guys can
come hang out watch a stream and meet
some of the other incredible people that
we have in the ij army my sister and i
also started a podcast recently so all
of this stuff can also be found in the
discord server so you guys can ask us
questions you can chat with us and it's
really fun because we even have we have
a music station where you can request
songs from dj mini matt oh gosh it's so
fun i love it it's like my new my new
hobby discord well i think that's all i
have to say i'll put links in the
description to a bunch of the things
that i've talked about in this video the
only thing is a lot of the stuff is on
back order or it's going to take a lot
of ship due to the nature of the
availability for things i mean who would
have thought that there would have been
a
high demand for webcams in 2020
i don't know but there was
and they're all sold out let me know if
you guys have any suggestions for
anything else that you think that my
streaming setup needs and i will see you
guys in my next video i look forward to
making version 2 of my streaming setup
hopefully sometime soon
see
ya give me that that's mine you evil
witch you're an idiot get your own
snowball you pig oh my god i just added
kk slider i didn't and he's naked
amazing this is amazing are you gonna
move on to the great unknown perhaps to
pro-max you don't know where you're
headed you should move to my island i've
got a little place for you you were
secretly hoping you'd say that